thank you
turning to the labor day weekend travel
rush it seems nothing can get in the way
of americans and their vacation plans a
recent survey found that 53 percent plan
to go somewhere this weekend despite
inflation high gas prices and flight
delays according to triple a bookings
are up 22 percent over last year for
domestic travel and up 104 percent for
international travel chris van cleeve is
at washington's reagan national airport
chris good morning what are we looking
at right now
well good morning michelle we're looking
at one of the peak times for flyers to
get out of town and start enjoying this
last
long holiday weekend here of the summer
the department of transportation is
taking advantage of that to roll out a
new tool that hopes better informs
flyers of their rights but we also know
that among the millions of people that
are on the move some opted to drive
instead of fly because of all of these
disruptions and that's despite those
high gas prices
if it's labor day weekend the
steinberger family is on the move
usually flying out of new york for one
last summer adventure but this year
they're hitting the road the fear of our
family being stuck in the caribbean or
in another part of the united states
definitely did weigh into our decision
on doing a drivable destination while
the national average for a gallon of gas
has fallen steadily for the last 11
weeks currently hovering around 3
dollars and 80 cents driving will still
cost the steinbergers about 20 percent
more than it would have last year
oh my goodness if i had a dollar every
time i had a canceled flight i wouldn't
have to work and for flyers more than
two thousand flights have already been
canceled so far this week airlines and
air traffic control staffing issues this
summer led carriers to reduce schedules
and step up hiring but more than a
thousand airline pilots started the
holiday weekend on the picket line at 13
airports nationwide a one-day protest
over pay and scheduling all these pilots
are off duty today they're here on their
off day to show their frustration with
delta management
this comes after a summer of headaches
where nearly a quarter of flights have
been delayed on average by nearly an
hour in june that sent airline
complaints up 270 percent compared to
2019.
now the department of transportation is
launching this new consumer dashboard
showing how the nation's airlines
compare when things go awry if they're
not prepared to serve customers well
we'll be ready with more rules and more
enforcement as needed
secretary of transportation pete
butterjudge says airline performance is
improving but there's more work to do
how do you feel about going into the
labor day weekend i do think the steps
that have been taken so far are going to
be helpful going into labor day but i
also do not believe that the system is
where it needs to be
and delta says those pickets did not
impact its operations yesterday and said
the move by pilots is really more about
leverage during contract negotiations
gail
chris thank you with